[Applause]
there's a way to avoid this problem a
way to avoid having a proof
that says hey this is cool but right we
can prove this without the
the but you know the however we can
actually just use the classic
form of this proof which will limit us
to
just integer values of m the classic
proof which i'm about to present to you
for demoira's theorem think about this
what
knowledge do we have what kind of area
of mathematics that allows us to prove
things
where only integer values are relevant
maybe your brain is ticking
over because we read it we met it not
that uh long ago
we're going to use the principle of
mathematical induction now i always used
to think of it as kind of like this
shortcoming
of mathematical induction that it was
only true for integer
values i was like ah well that's kind of
a bit of a pain isn't it but actually
it's sort of elegant it's kind of like
using the right tool
for the job um you know if we want to
prove that something is true only for
integer values let's
prove it true using a tool that is
suitable to integer values so that's
what we're going to do here
now i do want to remind you that
mathematical induction because the whole
idea is
you kind of are knocking over a set of
dominoes it has to start somewhere
and then it goes in integer steps up to
infinity right
so we have to choose a starting point
which kind of
has its own challenge because i want all
integer values
including negative ones so there's not
any neat starting point
that i can go from the you know a
beginning and then go in one direction
because you'll always miss
the other half of the integers right so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
sort of start at a pretty standard place
which is zero
um you know often proofs by induction
will start at one or zero
most of them will start there i mean
sometimes they start at weird spots but
this is fairly common
i'm going to go from zero through the
counting numbers one two three four and
so on and then what we're going to do is
make a slight modification a bit of an
addition at the end rather than a
subtraction
um to sort of capture our negative cases
as well
okay so we're going to prove demolition
theorem is true by mathematical
induction
you may recall that uh proof of
mathematical instruction
essentially have three steps we're going
to test what we call the base case which
in this case
is n equals 0 the first time that we're
considering
for this um statement over here to be
true we're going to test
where they're going to assume that it's
true for some general case usually n
equals k
and then we're going to use that
assumption to prove that it's true prove
that's the third step
for the next step k plus 1 if it's true
for the previous step n equals k so
let's have a go
step one is test so i'm going to do this
in some colors just so we can follow it
more easily
so we're going to test for n equals 0.
here we go
what is the left hand side and the left
hand side will just be equal to
cos theta plus i sine theta because
remember we
unlike before when we were just trying
to show there was a problem
and we tested a particular value of
theta i need to prove that demand
theorem works for all values of theta so
that's why i'm leaving it there general
i raised that to power of 0 but anything
to the power of 0
is by definition 1 so i can state that i
then have a look at the
right hand side and i'm going to get cos
of
0 theta plus i sine
of 0 theta it's just me doing straight
substitution
that's weirdly cos of 0 plus i sine 0
which i've already done
a couple of times earlier today that's
going to be 1
plus 0 i which is 1 as required that's
the left hand side as well
okay so far so good i've tested for my
first case
now this is the easy step i'm going to
assume
that this statement is true except
rather than for some
general n i'm going to assume that it's
true for some specific
k so i'm going to assume that this is
true
where i've got k's instead of n's so i'm
going to put that k
up there okay here and k
there so this is assuming that it's true
for n equals
k and now i'm going to prove that it's
true
for n equals k plus 1. so what's that
going to look like well it's going to be
cos theta plus i sine theta that's
raised to the value of k plus 1
equals cos of okay here we go big
brackets k
plus 1 lots of theta
and then sine with k plus 1
lots of theta okay that looks good
to me so from here i'm using this as
my foundation right this is the n equals
k
case and now i need to prove like i
don't know that this is true
i'm going to try and prove the k plus 1
case so start from the left-hand side
stuff on the right hand side
in many ways it doesn't really matter
but i think it might be easier to use
the assumption
if i start from the left-hand side so
here comes the proof
i'm going to say the left-hand side
equals and i'm just going to take it as
written
here it is and i accidentally brought a
couple of extra brackets along for the
right okay there we go
now i'm just going to start doing some
algebra on this right k
plus 1 as the power means that this
thing gets multiplied by itself
until k you've done it k times and then
you have one more time that's the plus
one
so therefore i'm going to write that one
more time as a separate thing right
so it'll be cos theta plus i sine
theta there's the the extra one and then
the rest of it is cos theta plus i sine
theta
to the power of k so you can see how if
i add these two indices you get the k
plus one up here
right what's great about this line is
you can see i can use
this this expression here i can do a
substitution
using my um using my assumption over
here and that's kind of the point of
proof by induction
so what i've got is uh this cos theta
plus i sine theta that term is hanging
out the front and then i put a big set
of brackets here
i'm going to use this because apparently
that's equal to
cos theta plus i sine theta to the power
of k i'm going to duplicate that
not move it down here
there is my substitution and i'm going
to say because i'm using the
inductive hypothesis here the n equals k
case i'm going to say by assumption
[Music]
okay so at this point um i've done my
substitution from
from this line uh into here and now i'm
ready to just kind of expand out and
hopefully i can use some trigonometric
identities to get
to this all right so i'm just going to
do the expansion so
first i get cos theta that's going to
distribute to both of these terms so
cos of k theta
plus let's see what am i going to get
here i
is going to be out the front and then
cos theta sine
of k theta that looks good now i'm going
to distribute the
the i sine theta to both of these terms
inside the square brackets so that gives
me
i of sine theta cos
k theta and then for my final part of
the
expansion whoops it easy i times i here
is going to give me i squared and then
i've got two sine terms
pairing together so that's going to give
me plus i
squared sine theta
sine of k theta okay
now this is great what i'm going to do
is uh notice that
i've got some real and imaginary terms
here yes so
this part here this is going to be real
it's got no eyes on it
this part has eyes on it at the moment
but the i squared is going to cancel to
give me negative 1.
and that leaves these terms in here
where the i doesn't cancel so i might as
well factor it out and that gives me
the imaginary term so on left hand side
here let's use orange just to
keep it consistent i'm going to have cos
theta cos
of k theta and then the minus comes from
the i squared along the end there
i get sine theta sine of k theta
and then i'm going to i'm going to take
out i'm going to factorize out the
common factor of i
and that leaves me with i'm going to
switch out the order here just because
of the normal way that i write this i'm
going to get the sine theta cos
k theta term there and then i'm going to
get cos theta it's just flipped around
there
the sine k theta another in fact i'm
going to write those as big brackets
just so i don't confuse them
and there we go so what have i got here
well if you have a look carefully at
this
remember when we're always proving
things we keep one eye on our current
working and another eye
on this right hand side that's where i'm
trying to go right i started with the
left which is here and i'm going to here
i've got a trigonometric identity kind
of screaming out at me right
this this here is a compound angle
identity except that the compound angle
that i've got
is not like a plus b it's going to be
cos of theta plus k theta so i'm going
to write that
theta plus k theta
and then i've got this i and i've got
another compound angle identity over
here except it's not for cos
it's a sine how convenient so i've got
sine
of again theta plus k theta and now
finally all i need to do here is to
factorize out the fetus
inside those angles there which gives me
in the first instance
the k plus 1 factoring out the theta
and then the k plus 1 again
outside of that theta and that is my
right hand side
as required so well done you
just proved um four n equals zero one
two three and so on we just proved that
demarva's theorem is true
for this set of um this part of the set
of integers so i should say i should
conclude therefore
i'm going to just take this statement
this
is true over here
and how did i do it it was by the
principle
of mathematical induction you should
always conclude your proofs
[Music]
okay now like i sort of alluded to
before we have kind of only done half
the job mathematical induction starts at
a point it's like oh look at this domino
and then it pushes all the dominoes over
after that using this mathematical logic
this mathematical argument
but because we have to start somewhere
in the case here we started with 0 and
then go
onwards we've left out n equals negative
1 negative 2 negative 3 and so on going
to
negative infinity so i have to deal with
that somehow
so the way i'm going to do that is i'm
going to say well let's just go back to
this right because
i'm considering you know all of these
complex numbers on the unit circle i
want to consider what happens when i
deal with negative indices so if i have
this
z equals cos theta plus i sine theta
which is
a complex number on the unit circle what
happens when i raise this to the power
of negative one
uh that was sort of the the
quintessential negative index and then i
can deal with
all of the rest of the negative indices
on the basis of what i learned from this
well a negative index is just division
right it's the reciprocal
of cos theta plus i sine theta so what i
can write is
this is equal to 1 over
cos theta whoopsie daisy i think i
grabbed it there it is
cos theta plus i sine theta and as soon
as you see this you should think oh i
want to deal with the fact that the
denominator is
complex what i can do is i can just
multiply through
by the conjugate of the denominator and
that will
realize my denominator so what i'm going
to multiply by
is not cos theta plus i sine theta it's
going to be cos theta
minus i sine theta so i'm going to grab
that
and multiplying by that over that
there's no change to the actual fraction
okay so this is good i can say 1 times
that conjugate is just going to give me
that conjugate on the top i don't need
to go that far over
what do i get on the denominator well
the reason why we multiply
by the conjugate is because we can use
difference of squares here right this
pair of denominators is in the form a
plus b times a
minus b so difference of squares of
course factorizes to give you a squared
minus b squared in that case in this
case it's cos
squared theta take away i squared
sine squared theta you can kind of see
where this is going right
this is going to be equal to i've still
got my cos theta
minus i sine theta on the numerator the
conjugate
but then what have i got on the
denominator well that minus and that i
squared are going to cancel with each
other giving me
plus sine squared theta and this is
delightful because i have the
pythagorean identity
on the denominator which means i can
just write the denominator as 1.
let's be super lazy and grab that
because i wrote it neatly enough i think
that's equal to 1. so therefore i can
say
that's equal to interestingly when i
take
the reciprocal of a complex number
if it's on the unit circle the complex
number that you get
is exactly the conjugate and you can
think about that geometrically as well
okay now what can i do with this well i
can actually use the fact
that i can raise this to um a power
a positive integer power using this
proof by induction that i just did right
i've just
built a foundation to say hey this demo
moivre's theorem thing it
works for n equals zero one two etc
um you know zero and all the positive
values so let's
raise everything you can see on on
on this left and right hand side to this
power what am i gonna get
well it's going to give me z to the
power of
negative 1 to the power of n on the left
hand side
but that gives me cos n theta
minus i sine of n
theta that's going to give me that on
the right hand side right so you can see
i've used demarva's theorem so long as
i'm still restricting myself to this
part because that's that's all i've
proven is true
right and the positive integers but now
i can say
wait i can i can work with this line a
little bit right for starters on the
left hand side i've got index laws
so i just get negative n over there
and then on the right hand side i can
use the symmetry of the trigonometric
functions this is this delightful result
being using over and over again right
cos is an even function so therefore
cos of n theta is the same as cos of
negative
n theta yes and here this minus i sine n
theta sine is an
odd function so therefore i can write
this as plus
i sine negative n theta
because of the oddness the odd symmetry
you get in that function
now what have we got here this is de
moivre's theorem
but lo and behold i'm taking it for
negative values of these arguments
considering that n up here has to be
positive so negative n must be
a negative number and it's the same in
here so therefore what i've shown
is that theorem holds true not just for
um
you know n equals zero one two one
following but also for
the negative numbers because i can
substitute anything you know into
n here that i like even if i get a
negative it still all
works using these properties so in
summary
um dwyer's theorem is marvelous but you
have to be careful
with it and even though this this proof
using mathematical induction seems so
much longer
than what we did before with the
exponential form of a complex number
and what's great in it is that you don't
have to say but you know you don't just
say
this proof is true but be cautious with
it
this proof is true and it's true for
exactly what it says it is for
n equals 0 and up to the positive
integer values and also
for the negative values that you get
down here